foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody that's here right now you're
in for a special treat actually because
before we even get into it we're gonna
get some comments so I am here with one
and oh Logan 2 and 16 Ryan who would you
trust more I mean Ryan you were saying
you do have more wins for what it's
worth to me I don't know okay Natalie I
did say to you before we started this
that we frame it as Logan has one win
Ryan has two we don't need to know the
second number we don't need to know the
two for 16. yeah
I I have a very small sample size like
you just said Natalie but
I've spent weeks harassing Ryan
um I'm not in front of the camera I'm in
I am in the chat just like everyone else
here like my boy Darian my boy B
Thompson you know and I'm just just
saying how's the Rat's Nest you know
he's pretty cheesy over there all these
chirps and eventually I felt so bad that
I had to come in and win a parlay for us
you know
um lead by example as they say but I'm
trying to kill all of that beef right
now and uh oh you're doing a good job
you're doing a good job this is her time
to make up Ryan you know we both want
the same thing right we want to win to
get rich right Rich winning
every week will slowly get you rich
though
it was selfless really you didn't do it
for you you did it for everyone else so
I I can appreciate that sentiment yeah
that's true a martyr of sorts okay yeah
thanks I will say Logan you dropped in
the chat before we started this uh Braun
Wade and Bosch referring to the three of
us we're the super team and then
darian85 asked who's Ryan out of those
three obviously like everyone would say
I'm I'm LeBron so that's what I said and
B Thompson said haha you wish he was
brawn
and now oh and now we're here and now
we're here are you still upset about
last week
all right we just have to wash last week
right we took a little break
now we're back to our winning ways
yeah I mean we reversed we were Natalie
you said it your post in the app
Community we reverse sweep last week I
mean right I I thought we weren't gonna
mention that well and I thought we
weren't gonna mention two for 16.
no one told me that so
we're changing the Vibes though it's
okay Fresh Start
there's a lot to talk about all right
there's a lot to unpack but welcome to
the show everyone I am Natalie I'm here
with Logan and producer Ryan of course a
Mainstay me and Logan are newbies well
Logan has the one win on the show so
just let it be known he's undefeated you
want to know undefeated 100 right I'm
here for the vibes
last time we're gonna mention it no more
fresh blood and this week let's hit a
parlay why not I mean that that sounds
good to me also wanted to give a shout
out to our boys Greg G regular and
bowling MB
um you're with you're with us in spirit
today we're getting this win for you all
right and to you guys didn't call
yourself Mainstays but you know this is
a tryout of sorts right the producer
came to me and was like our producer Max
was like you're clearly not the problem
here right it's it's Greg and it's
bowling that are the issues
parlay with them and I want you to pick
your squad so I went and I recruited you
know Dwyane Wade and Chris Bosh and here
we are guys
just said we have Natalie to save us
today you know I'm just gonna just
ignore everything bro I just said there
but
I'm certainly gonna try okay look I will
say Ryan I got producer just piped up in
my ear cannot confirm nor deny so I'm
gonna take that as we're The A Team
Logan
um I'm not sure any other way to frame
that I'll try to save us but I'm here
for the people and really I'm here for
Ryan Ryan I want to push your agenda
today because they beat down on you too
much and I'm sick of it okay I'm here to
Foster peace and of course get a win so
that that's what I'm into
should we get into it all right time to
drop those Best Bets in the chat family
I want all of the community's favorite
plays
anything sticking out to you guys
well I mean we got I'm in the shot right
now
let's see
will Greg's how does this affect Ben
Simmons Legacy enough enough from you
yeah we don't remember it's TNT games
right it's TNT games and remember we
don't talk about the Nets on on this
show it's only relevance it's like the
Kings right we don't mention the Nets we
don't mention the Kings it's only major
markets and it's only teams that are
actually relevant to the NBA so we don't
do we don't do those teams
um but yeah so we have the two games
that we have on TNT tonight are
Philadelphia 76ers uh and the Dallas
Mavericks and then the Los Angeles
Clippers and the Golden State Warriors
if you watch the show if you watch the
NBA and TNT I feel like the Golden State
Warriors are on literally
every single week
um so we'll get to them
we will get to them but I feel like we
got to start we got to start Logan
you're our you're our 76ers Guru
um yeah so the guru's fair I mean I made
a strict rule that I'd never bet on the
Sixers or against them just because it's
caused me it's like doubling down both
emotionally and financially right you
lose money you're also like miserable
that your team just lost but I'll be uh
an advisor a Sixers advisor today we
could call it may I may I throw you
throw you here early
and I wonder what the chat thinks about
this too James Harden's under how do we
feel what's what's this set at on here I
don't know what do we think
my first thought here here's what I
think Natalie where where's James Harden
oh right here sorry oh yeah I it's
reading is a problem for me uh we don't
take unders on this parlay that being
said that's not me saying no that's me
saying I have been in this situation
before I have proposed it under and it's
been shot down I'm here to accept it if
we all sit here and say take the James
Harden under if the chat loves it the
the chat though the chat hates unders
the chat if it was up to the chat we
would take every over for every
superstar throughout this entire sleep
but we're not gonna do that but I think
I I like I like it I I'm Logan thoughts
James Harden under right at 21 and a
half at 21 and a half and obviously I
mean that I need the B Thompson B
Thompson no unders already with this
yeah I saw it looks that is low he's
averaging 21 on the season the other
night it beats out he's got to step it
up maybe productivity lowers today I
don't know just throwing it out there
but new to the show happy to follow the
rules just food for thought food for
thought there's no hard rule though we
don't that we don't bet unders I mean
um or is there Ryan I saw that face a
Grimace a Grimace after I said that no
no I'm just thinking what Natalie said I
do enjoy the the subtle angle of uh
James Harden having to run around two
games in a row
hmm I will it's a good thing
it makes sense
he had 12. 12. okay let me look at pull
up the stats here
all right he had tough outing against
the Heat 23 points not too bad though 20
21 31 19. I mean
he's hovering right around this number
yeah in his last last five or six a
little bit of a coin flip but
what what if we do this what if we do
this what if we go down to
his alternate points and we take
under
I don't know one of these numbers which
one you feel most comfortable with
Natalie we got 24 and a half 25 and a
half 26 and a half 26. I love a good
minus 14.50
God please I'm just joking just joking
let's hear from the chat what do we what
do we like I don't know I like the idea
of going with an ALT line here I don't
know people in the chat though they are
very against unders so my early take is
is getting a lot of thumbs down uh well
spicy sponge also brought up a good
actually this is a phenomenal point that
Mavs don't play any defense at all he
also said Harden over is a yes but embed
rebounds is a lock locky and darian85
jumped in said my uh my MB play which he
bugged me and Logan about before the
stream and I don't mean to say but I
mean bugs in a lot no vegetarian yeah
anything plugged in a loving way let's
yes I loved it every time I get Darion I
get a notification from Darian from the
BR app a smile comes across my face but
he said embed over 10 and a half
rebounds I think why don't let's just
let's make it simple let's put it in
there start there yeah let's start let's
start there I've I've been hearing a lot
of MB boards in here
um
he was is embiid playing m Robinson 119.
he was listed probable this morning
um
I'm pretty sure he's suiting up tonight
and if we wanted to play that game where
we tease it down so we don't lose by the
hook we could just do because he did
also mention that we could do that we
could we could go to 10 plus here minus
200.
it's up to you guys I think we I think
we stick with the 10 and a half okay
cool
um
two comments I've got to call out real
quick
just because she's new I'll rock with
the under if you do 27 and a half that
my friend is like a minus 500 play might
not be able to do that appreciate the
comment though
um then we've got another idea from bk37
clay four plus threes
lots of value what are our thoughts
let's see what four plus looks like if
we want to switch to the late game
already Ryan
um
I mean yeah I have a feeling what is
this three-point line it's gonna be over
under four and a half like straight
we're talking minus 115.
like it's just the way the guy puts him
up
you know he's got like the unlimited
ammo cheat code you know he just like
keeps tossing them up there yeah four
and a half
I I I mean like yeah this is go right no
but bowling dropped two things one he
said I missed you guys a lot miss you
two bowling all right yeah even though
even though this is a you know this is a
tryout for your job yeah it's true
that's right this is maybe you should be
rooting against this parlay uh yeah
uh clay 20 plus points is a leg uh he
said Steph Curry's out and
uh pool Jordan pool is doubtful
interesting because Jordan pool is here
uh are are we accusing bullying of
trying to sabotage the parlaysia I'll
let the chat decide if he's if he's
trying to sabotage but I'm not saying it
uh we could do the threes four and a
half is a lot or we can go to the points
and see where he's at 25 and a half
he's 25 and a half if we tease this down
to say 20
where are I feel like we're already at a
good
we're in a good spot we're at plus 123
with two legs I'm into that yeah I love
that and and honestly I just want to
shout out Ryan when you weren't on the
show you gave us bucks money line I know
you loved it yeah this one I saw the
look on your face just now
um you gave us bucks money line it was
the first time we took a side in one of
these parlays and it's smashed no sweat
winner please chef's kiss yeah
so I think we have to take Bowlings
bowling's play as a a resident show host
here
I would agree
I I agree I just I mean that that's the
Vibes we needed to start the show with
Logan I mean remind me of my wins not my
losses Natalie what are we doing I mean
look we gotta uplift Ryan here he's been
beat down too much we haven't been
winning as much as we'd like we're
trying to come back from last week we
need Positive Vibes only especially for
Ryan so yeah Ryan I'm here don't worry
I'm I'm here in your corner never left
yeah thank you I know you've always been
you've always been in the corner
um bk37 said uh no one wants over four
and a half I said four plus well bk37 I
mean we got 20 plus points what are we
gonna do go all in on clay
yeah do you guys want to go all in on
Clay I don't think so we can't double
dip like that you know no and no and the
correlation there on the four and I have
threes you know when I see a line like
four and a half threes it's like I have
two thoughts I think the old me would
have thought you know this line is so
high I have to take the under
the new me is like
you know it's kind of like when you see
a total of 74 in a college football game
you know
meaning you before you hit the Starbucks
parlay or yeah
the flattering me flattering me now yeah
when he says when he says numi he means
the sharp B that's what that's right we
woke up today and became a shark boy
right uh not quite sharp yeah
but somebody who is let me let me see if
I can find the uh find the comment
uh gsmith813 Draymond over on assists
drop the lock Emoji uh went over in six
of the last ten and both games against
the Clippers this season
oh
that's our friend our friend Greg would
call that a scoop
yeah do you want me to get it oh yeah I
mean I don't
to be honest yeah just go ahead just for
the effect for the effect yeah
yeah there we go
right okay I got the ladle okay all
right oh perfect I'm seeing uh okay so
should we let's not skip over that we
liked that scoop the Draymond apples
yeah the assists
um
over six and a half
hands up
um
I let's let's see what it looks like
it's minus at this is
a thousand it didn't it did not do a
thing to this parlay
all right so we're at plus 155 plus is
there no five blows uh we could yeah we
could do over four and a half
so
so ah ah
not worth the squeeze I I don't think we
and we're at plus 188 with that now we
need something yeah we need something
better than that yeah uh darian85 asked
why do I why do I have a ladle uh one of
our Tech managers Chris uh heard us
saying Scoops so he brought this for me
also our producer Max is saying this
isn't a ladle this is 100 a ladle that's
like uh that's not that's not a lot
that's not a ladle
film
it's like a cervix if this is a spoon
this is the largest spoon I've ever seen
in my life have you ever encountered a
ladle I'm not sure you have because
someone who has would never accuse that
of being a ladle I was gonna let it
slide but if we're gonna revisit the
ladles like vertical it's more like up
down you know and it has like the
you know too much talk about cookware
we gotta get back all right so I'm
seeing Brendan Rich drop five or six
plays
yeah Kyrie over four and a half assists
he dropped the whole parlay should we
just
copy paste throw it up on the on the
screen and
and head out guys one of the one of the
plays he said was hard in under 20 and a
half points it's true
so okay we might have to revisit we
might have to revisit uh bk37 said uh
divincenzo points could be insane
especially if pool is questionable
that's a good point I
I have thought about that but Dante is
banned I would be down to revisit
Dante's reappearance yeah I was gonna
say
um it's we know how that Dante look goes
right it's like
I mean I think he does fire
him off that's the one thing
let me see yeah I I'm fine to pass so
fine to pass on Dante yeah Natalie
thoughts I mean the chat is loving does
the chat like Dante we do have to listen
to the chat I'm not getting those
accusations thrown at Ryan you know what
I'm talking about I've I've been going
through the chat trying to get a gauge
for the support here well actually
durian85 said we don't bet Dante so
that's actually pushing your theory so
maybe it's a sign I just ran it will
season there's about three more bands
yeah Dairy 85 knows ball he's in here
every week Darion
I know but as somebody who's also here
every week I think Darian and I need to
kind of come to a to a little bit of an
agreement here is is it okay to to
let him come back give him a shot at
Redemption
we have to be a show of Second Chances
here right we do
Maybe
it's the threes I see Adam Neuer says
over two and a half threes
you know
uh let's revisit Dante if we need some
juice if we need some juice maybe what
does two plus look like
two plus is probably gonna be gross yeah
my prediction mine is 552 plus oh wow
we're getting a lot of no Dante now
no Dante minus 550.
y'all sleep on oh my God there's like a
this is like turning into a Dante like
no Dante yes
Dante debate right now and I'm like in
the thick of it I'm watching them all
come in I can't even keep up well I love
there's Dante back and forth and then uh
oh Cruz jumps in here hard in three plus
threes
laughs
[Music]
uh bk37 says I don't want this to fall
back respect yeah yeah yeah I guess I'll
take the heat for you sure
we're gonna put we're gonna put Dante on
the back burner for now all right
now I'm Dante divincenzo based takes in
the chat
Al George 20 plus Paul George 20 plus
I remember looking at that before the
show it didn't look too egregious odds
was
we have autumn in here just repeatedly
saying it's a lock and I'm not gonna lie
I'm starting to believe him
yeah I mean when you come when you come
out of the Woodworks and your main take
is Dante divincenzo and you believe it
that hard and no profile big and no
profile but I mean to me there's
legitimacy there
yeah
I I will say the last time
James Wiseman jumped in here and I think
you'll remember yeah I don't want to get
James in trouble no I don't want to Jade
no if we jumped he jumped in here we hit
the parlay and then he got traded from
Golden State a few weeks later
that's all I'll say okay that's all I'll
say Okay deep breaths
yeah just okay now okay all right back
to it
back to it so we're at plus 210 right
now
three legs
I mean
think that puts us in a pretty decent
spot
to add to like
kind of like chopped down legs rather
than one straight one and a super chop
down one what do you think guys
I'm I'm with you I'm I appreciate that
logic I yeah I I like it I say here's
what I think
I'm gonna I'm gonna do something that I
don't want to I think we we should add
I do think that we should add
Dante divincenzo two plus threes and
then I think we should go back to the
earlier game and we should find a leg
there
okay yeah okay yeah I'm with it you know
we have to listen to the chat you know
I've I've dogged you for not doing this
right you know so I'm I'm fully
supportive of adding a leg that everyone
has been vouching for
somebody said wait I need a profile pic
to drop a lock no I'm sorry that was
nothing personal but
bring everything into account
does it feel wrong
to not have Luca in any sort of way here
a little bit I was gonna say I mean
the chat just hasn't I haven't seen that
much Luca in the chat let's see
anyone have any Luca plays they love I
see Bowlings typing
eyes threes his threes yeah that's one
you know I'm always in on taking Kyrie's
under
not for personal reasons though no four
personal reasons
yeah here we go
all right I like his threes I was saying
this to you earlier Logan like his
threes are at
two and a half
mm-hmm I'm pulling up Kyrie as well
that's intriguing
all right the guy this season is
shooting 7.8 threes a game
yeah we just House of Watts said Luca
Luca over threes
I know the volume's gonna be there right
right like you can't be that upset when
you lose a play and it's like yeah
anytime touchdown score bet or first
touchdown and the ball goes right
through his hands you had the right play
there yeah just didn't deliver
and and we'll be happy with the volume
coming from
from Luca right like
it just shoots so many and two and a
half does seem
low for him like I've I've swear I've
seen that number closer to Clay's four
and a half before you know
the chat is supportive that's I mean
that's all I'm saying we've got a lot of
positivity in here for that Legend I
don't know I think
should we Thumb Thumbs Up thumbs down it
from the chat oh Luca over two and a
half no no not yet not quite well here's
the thing we have five legs uh
I'm down to thumbs up thumbs down for
Luca over two and a half I if we're
gonna land on that we then need to
figure out how to bring this down a
little bit because we have
some wiggle room
all right now bk37 just dropped some uh
Sixers plus 12 and a half at minus 540.
do we we don't have a side in this in
this lay you know not like I already
said not a Sixers better but I was
shocked to see they were underdogs
tonight
uh that's yeah I was very surprised
um
yeah yeah he dropped plus 10 and a half
is minus 370.
and
they don't play defense bk37 who are you
referring to Sixers or yeah that was my
question um
let's see yeah I think he's talking
about the Sixers all right
okay are is there anything that you want
to chop down immediately like looking at
this parlay like anything we want to
tease down uh either clay or or
Paul George I don't like having two 20
plus scores in there
I I don't hate the plus 10 and a half
and then let's see if we can lose which
one would you guys rather lose Klay
Thompson or uh Paul George
now what do you think I I know my answer
but it's it's kind of personal
unfortunately well I I think that's when
I have to hear I need to factor that in
yeah oh no I mean clay has just like
ruined so many tickets for me slightly
on this do not bet list for you
I respect that if it's look that might
be telling you're involved in this
parlay it hasn't gone well before it
might be a sign
but yeah I mean the guy only shoots
threes as well right if he hits if he
gets his over on threes four and a half
five that's we're still not there you
know like
um
yeah I'd rather have Paul George in
there personally
but I'm down for takes
yeah yeah she just had two comments we
have ah no PG no PG yeah Michael Baron
doesn't hear no PG takeoff TG Dave
Rosenblum
oh god oh he's on a minutes restriction
still I believe that's a who scoop Paul
George smoke uh
smoke funny name uh it says Paul George
is on a minutes restriction is still I
believe pull right into that one
yeah that was great yeah
yeah you can easily score undefeated
you're undefeated on this show I I'm not
sure if the chat knows that
so maybe tonight's different we gotta we
gotta leave room for that maybe
tonight's different clay won't let you
down I don't know just throwing it out
there
maybe try I mean
man of the people right
men and women of the people right um and
we saw
clay a lot of people wanted Clay over PG
right so I say we just dropped PG from
there and maybe that's where we sub in
the
the Sixers all spread or something like
that well I already put the six results
spread in okay uh and I teased Luca down
to two plus without asking I'm sorry
guys I I tried to see if I could figure
that out on my own that was that's on me
that's on me that's on me
um it doesn't seem to have done the
trick here looking at it so I mean when
you when you look at plus 220 like we
can get like a leg that's
around like what minus 120 What minus
150 to add to this and we'd be at our
spot right
so just so because there was confusion
we have Joel embiid over 10 and a half
rebounds yeah Philadelphia 76ers plus 10
and a half Luca doncic two plus made
threes and then Dante divincenzo two
plus made threes I really I I
unfortunately very much disagree with
Darion I think the play what we the the
play we should be making here is over
two and a half for Dante and then we can
tease down clay to potentially like 15.
I think that's a good kind of meet you
in the middle type of yes
about to say yeah I think that's
actually gonna do the trick up to 12
boards is a take
I like playing that safe I'm not gonna
yeah let's I I yeah because he ten and a
half yeah the chat was mainly against
that too after we put it in so I don't
know I'd rather go with 10 and a half
all right so four legs plus 354 here
hold on let's do this
it's a new trick I've learned
uh oh let's let's see the trick there it
is over 17 and a half or oh wait let's
see if this does it ah no so close but
no okay if we do if we want to do over
17 and a half if we don't want to get to
straight 20.
I think we could do that
hmm
I mean what was what was the Jordan pool
scoop we got
that he used earlier doubtful that's a
good uh
music to a clay better is ears
that would be true
I'm checking the status
it's officially available for the
Warriors tonight so okay all right all
right what kind of Scoops where are we
getting our news guys this I don't bring
this out for no reason but I did today
you called it a little you want Scoops
and you have a ladle I look I don't that
was a little bit I can't side with you
there Ryan I can't fine yeah no I get it
I get it
I think
I think I'm thinking I'm still seeing a
lot of Dante stuff in the chat but I
think this is this is one time where
you know we have a bunch of different
takes around this Dante figure right we
we're giving him a second chance though
you know this is this is a new beginning
show
yeah I think this is uh this is a trust
us type of play you know what I mean
where it's like if and unfortunate you
know fortunately for you guys
unfortunately for me I'll have to face
the music next week uh if this doesn't
hit so I I will get the Dante hate if
you guys don't see Ryan here on the show
next week yeah I think you could it'll
be Natalie or Logan taking my place I
think you could put the pieces together
and well I don't know why that is
um
all right guys I think this is it I
think so just to review it Joel embiid
over 10 and a half rebounds
Philadelphia 76ers plus 10 and a half
Dante divincenzo over two and a half
three pointers made Luka dances two plus
threes Klay Thompson over 17 and a half
points
plus 410
screenshot it don't don't we're gonna
create some bets right now so don't in
the middle of that be like oh what's the
parlay and then you know Natalie asked
me to reread it four times like Greg
does don't do that screenshot it and
then you won't have questions
most definitely be on social in the
betting stream as well
if you guys need
um should we should we grade the BET
let's let's
Choose Wisely
what do we have
um well we just had someone say it's a
lock so I I mean that's all I needed
we're not creating Dante de vicenzo bets
we're not trading that's all of it is
uh yeah I'm get I'm getting too much
pools cleared to play it's you're late
you're late okay that's just what it is
uh okay
I want to be a special guest if Dante
don't hit from B Thompson
we'll see we'll see what we could do
there I see uh Harden two plus threes
I you know that leg might be minus 3 500
but what do you guys think
minus 3 500.
[Music]
um
would be helpful for sure yeah right
okay let's just say let's go over two
and a half because the line is two and a
half and it's minus 140. a to f
thoughts
I'm gonna go B
I mean I think
yeah
decent play I think he's been he had a
huge game the other last week when we
took him to get his assists scoring wise
I'm sure you guys remember that so maybe
there's some regression on the scoring
side just to be for me
uh for me he yes you were correct he
came nowhere close to our assists that
we teased down for him last week uh he
gets an H minus for me
yeah H minus he broke the scale on hello
I'm willing to go you don't do that to
us
okay strong strong take Ryan for the
people gonna read the par layout one
more time
this really never ends
this never ends I'll do it I'll do it
for you Natalie we needed a reaction you
know I'm in your corner you can see it
on the screen
um look he's he said he was very
forceful when he said he was done so
take your screenshot but as always pop
you guys could create this parlay with
us let's get a win for Logan and Ryan
and myself Natalie appreciate all of you
joining us let's cash tonight and we'll
see you guys next week
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you